[Music]
welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
sound board experience Thank You to
expressvpn quit and seeking for
sponsoring today's episode the day our
guest is the wonderful and illustrious
john mclaughlin more popularly known as
jacksepticeye 20 million subscribers 10
[Music]
views oh my gift I'm doing it not so
close yeah like 9.9 I mean you just hit
20 million right yeah like four days ago
that's insane like 20 that's so far I
know
and every time it's like you you hear
the numbers go up and up and up and then
I was like I rolled it out to somebody
in my 20 million that's a lot of zeros
[ __ ] weird yeah I I don't know why
how I mean do you ever expect like okay
it's gonna slow down now yeah I think
everyone kind of never stops let's go in
there I don't know I must have a
wiretapped in somewhere I have a secret
upload button to get more subscribers
yeah I don't know yeah that's crazy
coconuts
well anyway welcome to Los Angeles
thank you a good Irish boy yeah oh I
haven't burst into flames yeah oh yeah
it'll happen I mean your idea that's a
joke about you being paralyzed soon yes
you're not that pill no it's not that
bad it's situation is not that but it's
pretty [ __ ] bad I mean my under well
yeah you've been here a long time where
you just fail
I mean well frankly I mean look I don't
leave the house you don't have to go in
the Sun out here that's true I mean yeah
my roof that's the problem with LA you
go outside you die yeah you know or you
get stuck in traffic so by the way do
you live in Ireland or do you live in
the UK where do you live right now I've
lived in Ireland until last year and
then I moved to Brighton so I've been
living there for a year since May
that's where PewDiePie lives right yeah
you guys you guys hang out you guys
brothers yep hang out make out all the
time no it's weird cuz we we live in the
same town and he's like a 30-minute
drive for me
I almost never see each other thirty
minutes is like five minutes best
friends 30 minutes I'll talk to you
something yeah we see just like once a
month maybe yeah it's kind of like 30
minutes same time it's also like I'll
see you next year yeah yeah and then
I've been doing tour stuff and
everything and he has his own stuff
that's he's going on so we never like
find the right time why'd you move to
Brighton mmm I always kind of moves I've
wanted to move anyway and I thought well
I'm gonna move to LA that seems a bit
fairs yeah a lot going on there I've a
lot to figure out
mm-hmm I was like well I could have
moved to London but that's too hectic I
don't really like London to live I was
like oh Brighton I went to visit Felix
and fell in love with it seems like a
nice little spot yeah lovely out on the
beach nice and cozy the people there are
nice you go to the beach not really it's
not a real beach it's like a yeah you
never really have the weather well
Elliot kinda has the same problem it's
like come to LA for the beaches but
never go in it because of the water so
cold all the time have you been in the
beach here in LA no down off the beach
it yeah don't bother about it so far
away I don't want you don't worry about
it
don't leave the house don't go to the
beach Shelly's great yeah
it's lonely make a lot of friends what
brings you out to LA cuz you came out
here on an extended trip right like
you're out here for a couple months you
kind of escaping a little bit would you
say getting out here and kind of just
yeah hey my life you know a life yeah I
wanted to become a movie actor really
reach Hollywood no come on yeah that's
how long it takes yeah okay four years
I'll see you on TV somewhere I don't
know I kind of I've always wanted to
come for a while and every time I come
here like we've been trying to do this
for a long time I remember when you
started off you're like you should do it
yeah that was in town for like a week
and nothing ever lined up ever yeah yeah
so I was like come for a month or two I
have a visa for tour anyway one of them
and yeah abused that and stay here for a
while and hang out with friends for a
longer period of time and then it was
supposed to be until August and then
tour leaves in August and I was gonna go
back afterwards and then my visa got
extended so I can technically stay here
a lot longer so nice why not I don't
need to be back home and Brighton for
anything anytime soon
just hang out here and do cool stuff but
you know you were I mean you've been
talking a lot about being burned out and
taking a break from you yeah is that
kind of is coming out to LA almost like
therapeutic kind of get away from the
life back there yeah which was weird cuz
I said that I needed a break and I was
getting burned out and I just needed to
figure out what I wanted to do what it
was like Ellie is not the place to go
find yourself I disagree by the way
really
I feel like Ellie gets a bad rep yeah
Ellis is a huge metropolis one of the
biggest I mean per square you know miles
it's enormous
there's so many different communities in
different you can be and do whatever you
want here I why everyone has such a bad
perception of LA well anyway so but I
mean you are in a sense kind of I mean
you out here kind of just trying to
figure things out or is it more just you
know coincidental yeah what bit of both
yeah I was I've just got really
miserable doing the types of videos I
was doing after a while it's like a
whole month where I was like this is
crap yeah like I'm uploading [ __ ] just
for the sake of uploading and I was so
stringent on my schedule and I was so
proud of that schedule I was like I
don't want to break that well your fans
could they tell yeah so that was what
made me do it cuz they they started
being able to see it and I was like well
if I'm not enjoying it you're not
enjoying it what kind of comments would
they say where you're like oh [ __ ] like
maybe just like I didn't seem happy I
don't have the energy I normally had I
look sad I looked tired which I fully
agreed with I was and then it just came
to a point I was like okay yeah I need
tip and I was coming here anyway so I
was like okay Oh on the way to LA I'll
just take a week off I've never ever
taken any time off YouTube in the five
years I've been doing it so I was like
ok full break no YouTube no Twitter no
tumblr no Instagram no none of that
right and I decided to just spend a week
on my own and it was great
got here hung out with friends
completely changed my mind again yeah
you're feeling better
Oh 100% I'm completely 180 done where I
was you feeling like motivated to but
are you are you afraid like if you get
back into it you almost fall back into
it cuz that was my problem was like I've
been through that same exactly I mean I
don't have a crazy upload schedule like
you were I mean you were doing two
videos the day for a long time five
years but then you want you started
doing one
a day and recently uh yeah well whenever
I'd have to go out and tour or something
I okay I bump it down but it was still
like still we're still worrying I
remember seeing you in New York
mmm cups couple years ago a 16 year it
was a long-ass time ago and and you and
Felix and Mark were there yeah
and I was like you're like oh yeah we
all made videos and we're ahead of time
and they're all scheduled to upload I
was like what I mean that's just [ __ ]
that's just twisted like there's
something [ __ ] up about this job in
particular yeah right I mean to be fair
my stuff is a lot easier to do than the
ones you did yeah but still let's I mean
you're still making two videos a day
okay again and you're still under the
same expectation your fans have
expectation you're the expectation of
yourself I mean our approach is
different but the consumption of time
and expectation is the same yeah I think
that's fair but like this job seems
particularly [ __ ] up yeah right like
what is it about because everyone's
talking about this thing of like burnout
right youtuber burnout yeah it's really
big right now everyone so we're we
haven't posted video we're ending on
yeah we're in the middle of burnout I
would say bro I'm fully burnt out like
there's no wax left in the camera I'm
new camera I'm taking out a new candle I
don't know what's that Kendall smell
like lavender jasmine no
lavenders flowing yeah I need a new
essence what's going on why why is being
a youtuber so [ __ ] up
we're all Psychopaths I don't know
really I think it's good well you
started because you love it and then it
becomes your job and then you have an
audience and people to take care of and
you want to do the best you can and it's
just a platform and a job that you
you're not really allowed take time well
allow it you can do whatever the [ __ ]
you want right but it's just not in your
best interest to do it and no one's you
don't you're your own boss you make your
own hours you make your own schedules
and that's the curse I think yeah and
now it's just YouTube's just in such a
weird place anyway with all the [ __ ]
that's been happening over the last year
or two years and now they're trying to
diversify their revenue
streams and everything so everyone just
feels like on that treadmill more than
ever I think right and then it's just
coming to a head and then one person
talks about it what spurns another
person to talk about and then ten other
people start talking about it yeah I
know everyone's able to talk about I
think part of the problems I think
everything you said is exactly right
isn't like when you're your own boss and
when you're involved is something as I
mean I want to say talk super that's not
specific it's just so like you're on the
treadmill you're on there in the hamster
wheel and it's just like you got to keep
the Machine rolling and the mentalities
on YouTube have changed a lot over the
years like three years ago the gaming
scene was all collaborative all the time
it was in your best interest to collab
with people and like beauty gurus and
everybody would be doing it and now no
one doesn't because everyone's afraid of
stepping on each other's toes everyone
wants to insulate their own brand and
build it as far as they can and
everything it's very our self involved
so one thing I was gonna say is that I
think now it's more competitive hmm cuz
bat-like I mean if you ask average
ten-year-old what their dream job is
everyone wants to be a youtuber yeah and
it's like so competitive and it's so
hard to become to you know earn a living
on YouTube I'm a big youtuber that I
think that's part of what's so toxic
yeah about what it's becoming you're
definitely right I mean it's just not
and we can all see each other's we can
see what each other makes but if you
make a certain amount of views like
somebody else you kind of know what
everybody's making so every youtuber
kind of knows but if your subs you can
see your views you can see your like
yeah how interested people are the
comments are everybody's just like well
mine's better than yours
mm-hm and then if your yours isn't
better than then then you do some weird
[ __ ] to try and get it to be better than
somebody else it's a lot of like it's
not it's not friendly rivalry anymore I
don't think there's no case if somebody
uploads something you think it's cool so
you like want to do better now it's a
case of like I can [ __ ] do better
than that and you try and [ __ ] all over
somebody else that's that that's what I
feel like YouTube at large is now
everyone's trying to be better than each
other in that way I guess whatever came
became popular you're like I swear I
feel like I in some way had played a
role now I do though because like I feel
like when we first started coming up
popular on YouTube it was from reaction
videos
and like [ __ ] on people just like I
mean you know choose your target wisely
but like you you bait I mean our early
videos were just really [ __ ] on
people I mean and I think that all we
did commemorate what people - no I know
but like I don't I'm not gonna say that
I'm like holy responsible for like this
trend of like commentary channels which
are basically just solely almost talking
[ __ ] another creator yeah
but like it's definitely a fad that came
up around the time we started doing it
yeah well we helped popularize it I can
say that well that's what I'm saying
like you guys start it off and you
whatever way you perceive it but you've
picked your targets properly you pick
people that you felt like were valid in
criticism you're not [ __ ] on someone
that's just the entertainment factor of
it it's like it's a bit more embellished
and it would be but then like I said
somebody else sees that and they want to
do something better and they want to do
something crazier and get more views
than you so then they end up just
[ __ ] on people yeah and then it
becomes a thing it's like like like
there's like see I see this a lot where
it's just really popular content on
YouTube right now is like it's easy to
[ __ ] on someone who's being you know
being creative mm-hmm and maybe it's not
your style maybe it's not a video like
and so it's so it's so easy and people
do this and people love watching it of
being like this person's not funny yeah
and it's like well they're making
something original and you're just
[ __ ] [ __ ] on them for that yeah I
don't know maybe I'm just my mentality
is changing but I see that a lot on
YouTube and it's like you the people who
are trying to be creative actually put
themselves out there it's so scary to
put yourself out there on YouTube these
days and be authentic and try to be
creative in the original because there's
so many [ __ ] and there's so many people
waiting to just eat you alive yeah as
that you're not doing anything wrong you
might be unfunny in my opinion but like
what do I have to fleece you're trying
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] on you for being
unfunny yeah cuz the YouTube audiences
have just changed now it's like they all
do that now
it's very rare to have a community where
everyone's actually positive all the
time because right you're not you're not
an up-and-comer anymore it's not a new
job to do anymore you're not like the
underdog anymore everywhere there's more
money involved in YouTube now than there
ever husband and I think the audience
were very keenly
we're of that and that they want to poke
at people because they feel like it's
easier to do it's like well they have
money it doesn't matter if I say this
[ __ ] to them yeah well we're still
people at the end of the day so I have I
mean that's definitely a big part of it
I think yeah
it's just a whole bunch of building
blocks that makes a difference to on the
burn out because yeah you everybody even
the people who talk [ __ ] on say like oh
this one's not funny that's all their
videos they're gonna be more stressed
out because they're afraid that their
[ __ ] coat they're you know colleagues
are gonna call them out for [ __ ] up
and everybody's walking on eggshells
yeah because it's just like a giant mud
slinging contest these days on yeah I
mean we went through a huge varied of
like drama and community and reactions
and everything like that circle just
went around and around for like a whole
year yeah and then I think that just
fundamentally changed everything after
that row it's like communist Russia get
dragged down as the middle of the night
it's human nature everyone wants to take
down somebody else everyone wants to
find the thing it's like I'm positive
and energetic all the time but so people
think I have like some weird seedy
underbelly like I have like a weird pedo
ring or something that I'm keeping
secret that they're like somebody's
waiting to find it out well that would
explain why you're so energetic and
happy yes that's why I played happy
wheels all those years whatever everyone
just [ __ ] waiting to find that thing
about yeah I mean you get [ __ ] on
YouTube right I mean a lot of I think
people love or hate you right would you
agree with that yeah why do people like
what is it do you think that people hate
about you I don't know it's cuz it's
whenever you watch my content I'm
obviously very boisterous and very loud
and very energetic but some people
either see that as genuine interests and
energy and enthusiasm but to another
person it's completely obnoxious and
that's like I completely understand that
there's if I watched it I'd probably
have some sort of like thought process
going on it is very yeah I mean I don't
I don't hate anybody who doesn't like
what I do was fine does the hate bother
you does ever get to you it used to
because I I'm personally once it's like
make sure everybody's okay everyone's
having a good time and I just wanted
everybody to like have fun and then when
somebody doesn't have fun you feel like
it's your responsibility to make them
have
at this point I'm like okay you can't
win everybody yeah I'll just be happy I
mean there's still 20 million people on
the channel that's a very very much yeah
you can't really say [ __ ] at certain
point when you have 20 million
subscribers yeah I'm not any sort of
like egotistical way but it's like
clearly I've done something wrong some
people have exactly some an
understatement yes I was like how feed
into that positive aspect of the
community rather than worrying about
what everybody else is going to say do
you ever feel like you don't get enough
credit in a way and let me let me
explain because a lot of times like
people like you and Mark computed by who
play people would say oh you just play
video games and and you're so and you
have so many so much you make so much
money and you have so many people who
love you and watch you all you do is
play video games but clearly there's
some more going on that you feel like
you don't get enough credit when people
say that to you yeah I'd say so I'd say
that's fair because it's what are they
missing it's it's the whole aspect
outside of what you record yeah like
recording a game sure day after day
that's an easy kind of thing to do you
sit down you turn on the camera you
record but you have to find the games
you have to find stuff that people want
to see when it's daily everything like
fluctuates so much and you have to like
be always kind of there for your
audience and I'm very heavily involved
in my audience and interacting with them
so it's like after the video goes up
it's like well now I'm on social media
and I'm interacting with people and I'm
making sure everyone's okay and I'm
reblogging fanart I'm like tweeting out
at people and everything so it's it's a
whole lot more than just sitting down
recording the video and you see a 20
minute video like when I was recording I
was it's obnoticus it was like like
sometimes it was an hour-long video but
that was like a two and a half hour
session let's chop down and that was
going out every single day so it's like
sure in its its isolated bubble it's an
easy thing to do to play a game and
react to it but to do it that
consistently for that long I never take
a break I feel like just insane man hour
yeah so it's just like it's not hard to
do it's hard to keep it up yeah and I
mean you find your rhythm yeah I mean
the thing is like yeah once you start
like seeing your channel growing and you
start making money it's like really
motivating but you get used to that yeah
and then
like it's I don't know it's hard it's
like you well it's it's that thing
especially with my channel because it
rose so quickly and then it obviously
plateaus out every channel does it's
healthy it's fine
yeah but some people when their channels
plateau they freak out and they feel
like they have to do something else
there's no insane growth is no growth at
all to them sure especially when you're
used to like yeah like this steroid
injection so it's like it you start off
and everyone's like oh this is fun this
is cool and then it's like oh well now I
kind of get your gimmick I know what you
are like what else can you do and that's
the trap people can fall into then
that's how you end up recording your
dead body in a forest somewhere because
you feel like you have to keep on
stressing so you're you're saying that
you were basically just maintaining what
made people like you to begin with yeah
right but your channel hasn't really
slowed down I mean it's not easy no it's
not just sending yourself and be like
what I'm doing is is good enough yeah
and keep doing it and just be stable
well that was always my mentality it was
like sure it's easy to be like well if
this keeps going I'll be a 10-million at
this point but I mean no one knows
what's gonna happen so it was always a
case of like okay these people are here
now today so entertain them keep them
happy be happy with them and do what you
want if if you keep doing it obviously
you're doing something right
more people are gonna learn I think that
mentality of always like looking ahead
of like oh I could get this amount
that's a very slippery slope to go down
most f-fine no you're getting [ __ ]
real yeah we are covering sit so much
ground oh keep up everybody am [ __ ] let
me hit them with one of these remember
was still here yeah we can watch it that
you followed the Roseanne thing not that
we need to get into it I just thought
it's just through Twitter have you heard
this Suzanne did she actually say that
yeah I mean we talked a lot about so I
don't want to get repetitive that
happened when I was on tour they reckon
and we all woke up in the tour bus and
looked at our Twitter feeds and going oh
no well this was from her apology video
oh good apology Rosaria yeah I mean once
grace listen
hey you know clearly a very stable human
being yeah that was my first thought how
do you like touring you you do a lot of
touring right I mean you seem to be on
the road somewhat frequently yeah we've
got like two legs of the tour so far
it's the same show every time but right
we kind of segment it out
no I love live shows it's like like
creator and audience like in the same
room together being able to do whatever
the hell you want and then entertaining
them having that direct live feedback is
so much fun
I think that was part before the burnout
setting because I did that and then I
came back to my videos alone in my
bedroom man no one's here to listen
right now and I kind of gets in your
head a small bit so I had to
Rikka [ __ ] my my brain right I never
said that word before my life I'm fully
on board with that
what do you do in your show it's it's
like a it's like a 90-minute stand-up
show so it's like a comedy show um sort
of about my life and then talks about my
my childhood my teenage hood in my
adulthood so it's in three acts and then
you talk about your childhood and
there's like good gaming memories from
my childhood so you get people up to
play a game from your childhood and then
that's insane you get on a 90 minute
single man yeah shell when games are all
about experience and overcoming your
obstacles which life is about and then
you move on to your next stage of life
and you just keep going and just tell
some funny stories from my life I guess
where can people get tickets if they
want to catch you are there tickets
available still you sure can you can go
to jacksepticeye tor.com to get your
tapes now get the word out eight come on
European tour dates went on sale today
get get your tickets Jack I am buy show
comedy world tour a life filled we've
done one live show and it was like an
amazing experience it was so it was
magical honestly in a way it's so
intense like how many people were there
it was like 200 I mean it was a lot of
people I mean you probably what what
size what size you do it's a it's
between like 1500 to 2000 which is we we
have done venues were it's like 600 800
yeah depending on
but yeah so we just we played a comedy
store here in LA yeah just to kind of
test it out hmm and I mean it was it was
really amazing but it was just so much
work and it was like so stressful
putting it together yeah cuz it was also
live streamed we live stream I swear to
go and set up all the cameras and do all
the [ __ ] and I was like man but you guys
it'll come right well yeah yeah yeah so
I I work with the the game groom stay
have a Tori hello they produce it for
you see you very much just you're able
to show up yeah and just do your thing
so I just wrote the material and
practiced it in there how long it take
you to rehearse it and prep for it for
these week you prepared it in a week
yeah but like how long till like
memorize it and rehearse in [ __ ] I mean
it I never really like fully wrote it
down
it is scripted but it's kind of just in
my head as I go through how long and and
then how long before you did performed
it a month I think and how was the first
show great potential and yeah and you
didn't you didn't really rehearse it I
mean I did in my head over and over
again but not like properly out loud
like start to finish it make balloon
animals
yeah [ __ ] no stop how how was your show
evolved because if it seems like if you
just have it in your head seems like is
every show very different I mean how
does that well the life stories are all
the same and the punchlines and
everything are all the same but there's
enough like improv room in between
depending on the audience because the
audience don't know what it is and they
don't know what to expect or anything
like that so when you start telling the
stories different jokes land with
different people so it's but that's your
Vaman do your fans there they're good
they're good they're very good crowd
yeah this is what I'm saying like you
guys did a live show clearly your fans
showed up to it yeah they're very
forgiving like the barrier for entry is
so much easier not going into a cold
room yeah yeah like you don't have to
prove yourself sign out yeah they're
very easy you should want to put on a
good show on something you don't want to
just get up and [ __ ] on stage and have
people cheer for you well that's my next
tour well then
the [ __ ] on stage yes jerk-off your
accomplice I call it circle jerking hmm
right get me of one VIP but like when we
do it it's the podcast right so it's
different every time so the threat of
bombing is is very much right there for
me I'm bomb I'm bombing right now do you
do you think it's do you think it comes
out of a fear of your audience no I just
think I'm an anxious well I'm just an
anxious person but but why I'm gonna get
[ __ ] therapy on your ass right yeah
like where does your anxiety start and
what from like what what triggers it to
like kick in bro waking up but don't
worry my eyes there must be some like
trigger factor to it like you're afraid
of not performing well or letting
someone down or well not being funny I
mean yeah you know it's pretty uh
stressful I don't know I haven't you
know I need to do you think your
audience are here just to watch you be
funny they're there to be entertained
right you know yeah to a certain point
but yeah I mean huge numbers people
showing up consistently they're here for
your personalities more than anything so
what you're trying to tell me is that me
just being me you tell me just being
authentic is enough yeah
wow that's [ __ ] up dude oh yeah sorry
YouTube 2018 be fake no you're right I'm
just honestly I'm did I get I got issues
we all have issues man I have realized
YouTube for a living
I've always had really bad anxiety I
have I had like generalized anxiety
disorder in college there's like very
very very difficult at that time and
still carry a lot of that weight with me
I don't I honestly haven't really ever
sort out my issues dude do you go to
therapy
no probably should know I got issues
backlog years
no it's from a wonderful man you go to
therapy I have started yeah you have
started for how long have you been going
I've gone to well I've gone to one so
far but oh yeah I have like a guy I want
to go like a whole bunch more
I'm here I have a bunch of friends who
all swear by it and have like so you've
gone when did you when was your first
session about a week ago okay and did
you guys have any breakthroughs or what
a little bit yeah really day one
breakthrough yeah because I know it's a
lot about well I think maybe just the
job we do there's it's like talking a
lot about balance that was kind of a lot
of stuff I came to terms with when I
took a week off I was like yeah what
makes a mess and I was doing that I had
never been anxious before in my life and
then in the last couple of months it was
like sitting down and all of a sudden
like this swell in your chest happens
I'm like like this is what's going on
yeah like I don't like this the best
line ever heard in eighth No
in eighth grade there's this great line
she goes it's like you know before you
get on the roller coaster and then when
you're done and you get off and it goes
away yeah but it's like you never get
the relief of getting being done with
the roller coasters that's how I feel
all the time right now you're anxious
right now right now am i that
intimidating it's not well don't flatter
me leges she beat you she's she yeah
she's blinking to the camera if you're
unsafe all right let's take a quick
break we've got a lot more to cover a
lot more good let's get into it I'm very
excited for the next topic so please
guys do not go anywhere we will be right
back
with Sean mcLaughlin your boy yeah boy
oh God
ela you have to be a complete psychopath
to be browsing the internet these days
without a VPN because everybody is gonna
be checking up your skirt I'm talking
about advertisers I'm talking about ISPs
I'm talking about the government they're
all trying to look at your privates
right up the skirt and basically when
you don't have a VPN hila you're letting
them do it okay your browsing history
everything even if you're not doing
weird [ __ ] like looking at hentai online
ela you're gonna wanna protect your
privacy because whom you don't want
anyone having that data
expressly being as easy as apps that run
seamlessly in the background of your
computer phone or tablet you turn on
expressvpn protection only takes one
click expressvpn secures and and
immunizes and then
I just minimizes your internet browsing
by encrypting your data and hiding your
public IP address you got to protect
yourself with expressvpn and it costs
less than seven dollars a month I'm
talking about phones I'm talking about
tablets I'm talking about desktop
computers you don't want these crates
having your data you know what I'm
saying like Amazon's got this and like
all these advertising people they've got
like a cloud of like oh I know when
you're on your period I know when they
say it's a creepy and I don't like these
guys are the best expressvpn protect
your online activity today and find out
how you can get three dollars sorry
memory months free at expressvpn comm /
h3 that's expr ESS VPN a.com slash h3
for 3 months free with a one-year
package go ahead and visit expressvpn
dot-com / h3 to learn more protect
yourself for Christ's sakes is an
internet condom would you would you put
your dick in some sleazy ass girl you
just met at the bar no you put on a
condom that's what expressvpn is strap
up
ela let's forget for a second about the
incredible vibrating features of quip
the incredible the fact that it is
hell's he said let's let's forget about
it for a second okay because we all know
the quip is an incredible vibrating
toothbrush it tells you how long you
need to brush and when to switch sizes
we all know that it's incredible for
that fact but here's what people don't
know about quipped that I think I need
to tell the bristle ok is the softest
it's the best it's so gentle on my gums
but it's so strong on my teeth and I
swear to god I'm not blowing smoke I've
tried every toothbrush Under the Sun
because I'm obsessed with oral hygiene
and my mouth doesn't come out feeling as
clean or as well taken care of as this
quip head because it's got like soft
bristles and it's got rubber on the
outside and sometimes I'll go in there
with a toothbrush and and it will be too
irritating on my gums and that you do
not want to mess up your gums because
let me tell you folks those do not grow
back treat your gums right and that's
what qyp for me is all about now
we all know as I said that it vibrates
it starts at $25 and it's pretty much
the god of toothbrushes ok but what you
don't know is how amazingly clean and
fresh your mouth is gonna feel after you
use this frickin toothbrush no I'm
telling you this I'm not this is the
only toothbrush I'll ever use because
it's the best and it's just that simple
and the price is right guys it's quick
if you haven't tried it try it now
because your mouth [ __ ] stinks
it's disgusting your gums are receding
your teeth are rotting out of your head
try this give it a shot see they don't
change everything for you I bet it well
quip starts at just $25 go to get quip
comm /h 3 right now
you'll get your first refill pack free
with a quip electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free at
get quit calm the /h 3 spell GT qu IP
come /h 3
thank you to sinky for sponsoring this
video
if you don't know what SeatGeek is it is
a ticket app for live events which
includes nb8 concert post Malone's
whatever if they've got tickets and it's
live C gigs got you covered
now here's what I like about ckick if
you go to their app you've decided
whatever seat you want to buy the ticket
for you have the view from that seat you
get a ranking 1 to 10 on each ticket to
let you know if you're getting a good
deal or a bad deal Green is good red my
friends is bad ok now here is where
you're gonna lose your [ __ ] because
we've got the hook up if you use code
h3h3 you get $20 off your first order
that's just 20 bucks free there's not no
BS they're just saying hey you know what
you want to go see a show you want to go
see a live event come do it with ckick
try out our app and we got 20 bucks off
your ticket that's it dude they're just
hooking you up
just click the me tab on the app and
enter code h3h3 for $20 off your first
purchase click the link in the
description to download the app I love
SeatGeek guys this offer is kind of
insane just $20 free to go see whatever
show you're thinking of because hey it's
gonna cost you 20 bucks more if you
don't use ckick so give it a shot and
see if you like it alright and you're
gonna love it
and we're back with jacksepticeye Sean
mcLaughlin that's me you can I like to
thank you last name you kind of looked
at me when you said we're back like I
was supposed to say something I really
Hearst something I really like saying
mcLaughlin it's a fun blocking it's like
mmm what's what Sarah McLaughlin is she
Irish spelled the same name Oh in the
arms of an angel I don't know I thought
for some reason that was common
knowledge no how many other mcLaughlin
so you're you are close friends with
mark markiplier right yeah got there how
close are you guys fairly close like the
internet thinks we are I was just going
to say how I mean like do you guys say
you guys have sleepovers
no okay do you think we talk every
single day because what I was because
the Internet is quite to the contrary oh
there's this phenomenon on the internet
that is completely baffling is that
there's fans of you and Mark they're
having like explicit oh yeah
grotesque actually sodomy pure sodomy I
mean yeah absolutely pure sodomy and
worse
yeah not there's anything wrong
necessarily with sodomy sodomy when you
say it's sodomy mean it's like a violent
acts it almost sounds like is there
anything like let's just put it that way
right and because you can make love to
somebody's [ __ ] but sodomy implies
something like nefarious am i right or
am I wrong Dan can you fact check the
difference of the definition of sodomy
is sexual intercourse involving anal or
oral copulation so you can just you have
a romantic xiety and YouTube and
depression - [ __ ] sodomy basically
what we've just established is that I
could sodomized you romantically yeah it
doesn't sound good that doesn't sound
good
totally sodomized this garage sodomized
love
that ever was yeah it's just a style
it's a it's a it's a lifestyle it's a
way of living but you know like they're
the breath of the work is insane like
this is a just trying to show the the
breath here there's like just hundreds
of fanfiction here yeah it's just
endless what is going on here well you
know what hold on to that bigos again I
think okay well here no no no you're not
just gonna put up like a very vulgar
picture are you
no but I want to read just an excerpt so
that the people at home can see what
we're working with you proud of me my
the I start made it it's not you you're
not doing it it's an interesting
phenomenon done I want to get into it
okay
you don't have your own fan fictions
nobody wants to [ __ ] me
no nobody wants to [ __ ] immediately no
seriously there's just like not at all
which is why this is so shocking did I
have like sex repellent nobody wants to
[ __ ] me for better or worse
Heelys the only one in the world that
wants to [ __ ] me and that's worked out
what do you what do you think it is what
do you think people don't to have sex
because I'm just like I'm physically
grotesque I mean first of all that's
pretty much I mean like you know I'm not
that easy to look at first of all great
well like you know body wise you nobody
wants to [ __ ] the Pillsbury Doughboy for
example I do
I mean I'm soft I would be some people
do but not the people that respond to my
is pretty dope yeah romantic sodomy
romantic sodomy so anyway here let me
just redirects or I'm not gonna to put
you through but there's just this one
this is just so powerful I started the
rest I I start thrusting matching his
vows shades of Jack when I hear Oh mark
I hit his prostate good and hard
daddy please hit that spot again Jack
practically screamed I hit his prostate
again again I jerked him off matching my
thrusts daddy I'm close me too kitten
okay I mean that's just the trip to the
air yeah I mean I'm there Ken I hit his
prostate one more time before he came in
my hand
Jesus not long after I released
is the last one so I'm not gonna just
tell you know not long after I released
inside of my pull out of him watching my
seed like these people are sick seed run
down his thighs i admire my writing find
synonyms seed yeah like that's just sick
like damn seed you know you don't get
your baby seed out down then i get it
out but i don't necessarily call it seed
because that just seems a little [ __ ]
i watched i pulled out and washed my
seed run down his thighs i admired my
work before he attempted to stand up but
fall right back down on the couch ouch
yeah it's gonna hurt for a company like
it was a [ __ ] Jackson Pollock he
planted some cz [ __ ] blame the garden
yeah it's gonna hurt for a couple days I
say chuckling getting up from the couch
I get a wet rag and help him clean up
but it's totally worth he says smiling
hey Jack yeah I love you I love you
still so this [ __ ] isn't there's real
magic sodomy yeah
the Deaf very definition of full circle
so what's going on here is this like a
mean yeah
is this like mean by definition probably
but like what are they joking though or
no a lot of this is not joking there's
people who this is their sexual fantasy
yeah is you two don't get I mean this
went on for like who's creating yours
who's creating this fans but like who if
you imagine somebody who wrote that what
do they look like in your mind
it's [ __ ] George or or Martin yeah
the hunkering over his typewriter that'd
be great if he actually wrote itself
he's the genius behind it will you be
upset if I pull up some art no I'm kind
of YouTube might be no I pulled I took
out all the grid test stuff a long time
ago this was this started getting very
weird but we've been very vocal about oh
I mean so much okay well back to that
one that one like as much as I don't
want to do that with mark that is
fantastic artwork yeah absolutely
there's a lot of a fertile loop
dedicated so whoever drew that good art
style oh you're holding a cookie that
you drop once you embrace him did you
notice that maybe we're exchanging the
cookie interesting detail that they
would include a cook
yeah this is old that's green hair my
little nipple pinch you know I had to do
it to him had to do it got him a
handedness
but I'm sorry to put you through this
I'm just like there's something like
really special here and that it's just
so incredible like that this is a thing
I mean that the way I've always tried to
see it is that at first me America
obviously good friends we got along very
well once you start doing stuff together
and you show that you have good
chemistry together like for Let's Plays
and stuff this type of stuff I think is
inevitable yeah I remember that one I'm
getting the [ __ ] that really looks like
they're good artists I guess it doesn't
look like me well your face is
obstructed by his mane beautiful kissing
motion let me just let me just say bro
I'm I'm half chubs right now really yeah
damn I don't want me to make it a full
chub or we didn't it'll pinch she wasn't
a seed [ __ ] oh that's all of them no for
the for the longest time people used to
do that like like very heavily
I mean Merrick said okay cept appliers a
thing we get it please don't do anything
explicit with it because it's weird it's
not like characters from a book it's not
like Johnny Harris it was like people
who actually know each other and get
along and have a friendship and then
they would do this and then it kind of
died down for a while and now it's very
open that we're not okay with it the
whole septa plier thing we're like
please don't very much like don't do
this yeah because before it was like do
it in like a friendly bromance kind of
thing but then people still kind of took
it further and further so now we're like
just just don't do it at all you get
weird interactions in real life because
I know you do events with fans like did
anyone like bring something that to you
people will yell stuff at us so like
during some live shows if I talk about
because there's section in my live show
price talk about something getting weird
with like YouTube popularity and someone
yelled out septa plier at me I was like
no stop kids here but yeah every now and
then somebody will say something about
it and it's still
on the internet and everything and
people still do it and I don't want to
take away from people's if that's their
outlet to create art and that's how they
really want to express themselves I
don't I hate being the person to take
that away from somebody but you could
feel personally by violate it it seems
like by it not violated it's just it's
something that I don't think needs to
exist
yeah I think I think it went too far
like jump the shark too much I know it's
like well you can't see it without
seeing that side of it anymore I think
so I think that's why I'm kind of like
yeah just don't do it at all anymore
whenever anybody does something even if
it's not explicit any more people will
[ __ ] all over them and get bullied for
everything and I don't want that to
happen here so just yeah damn you can
just draw us as friends or I don't even
be kissing all the time yeah don't want
it mean Ethan I be [ __ ] so honored you
have been fiction sodomy fan art dude if
you guys can draw me in Jack [ __ ] I'm
down I don't know about you but I write
down you have it you have a free pass on
this one a once-off don't worry it's not
gonna become a thing nobody wants to see
me naked bro you should draw Ethan like
super buff like just [ __ ] ripped draw
me is like a big gay bear big eyed Donna
a big gay hairy bear a beard with BDSM
nothing else but yeah it did get weird
cuz then any time it got weird between
me and Marcus any time we would hang out
we'd be afraid of even like be natural
yeah if there's a photo of you guys be
like hey and then all of a sudden all
these little yeah because we did like a
pax panel and we were playing cards
against humanity' with Ken and Felix
uh-huh and with some moments where we
like look at each other and like had
like fun interactive people actually
think that you guys do they think that
it's real our deal so great that people
think so I both want it to be real but
like so they'll watch a video of you
guys interacting and they'll see a
moment of you guys like catching eyes in
the back I knew that that like they're
just hiding their bisexuality Spira see
yeah it's like I miss that person
straight does that and you both have
earned relationship probably
relationships I mean it's not and then
like it's just it keeps going and going
and going
is that the part that bothers you that
people think there's a conspiracy that
you are a mark are actually in a
relationship secretly where's yeah
there's a whole lot to it that's been
going off like for years yeah with me a
little couples there they'd be like you
guys showed up together you guys
definitely need therapy that's [ __ ]
weird just the fact that we did that
alone yeah
damn it's fascinating stuff it's weird
the internet it's crazy place cuz I
don't see fan fiction really about like
on that degree about anyone else online
I don't know why it is they got you too
so fueled up maybe it's just you know
there's maybe there's a subsection of a
shared audience or something yeah it's a
tumblr thing right I don't
I noticed you say you spend time on
tumblr this is a tumblr phenomenon this
couldn't exist anywhere else we'll see I
like tumblr tumblr on tumblr I don't
know what to do on tumblr what do you
kids do one time what are you doing dude
you tumble bath tumblr is where all the
best fan art comes from I think okay and
everyone's like very engaged and it's a
it's an easy platforms like filter
through I think mmm whereas like
everything else is type in keyword how
do you browse tumblr what are you doing
tumblr tag same as anywhere else yeah
just search through and you see people
interacting with the stuff people
produce I just think of like furries and
like stuff like that well that's the
thing like that's that's definitely a
sight of Tom Berg yeah and anybody who's
on tumblr will say the exact same thing
and it pops up you almost can't avoid it
you're like hey flour Oh your mother's
day here's uh there's a brony taking it
up the ass there's there's porn bots on
tumblr so you'd be going through like
your regular self to be some fine art
some text post everything and all of a
sudden it's like a picture of a woman in
a bikini saying she wants to have sex
call her now really it's just like wow
okay I don't know this woman hmm it was
like wanna lick my [ __ ] do it I'm like
all right sure did you get her consent
and what was really weird about it
because you can tell it's just like
Instagram models or whatever
and then they're just obviously bought
so they find pictures that got
interaction or have semi nudity or
whatever in and then one time I was
going down and it was like a Jessica
Nigri picture right I was like want to
[ __ ] her do it and I was like what is
that was weird
yeah that's so in like I know her
actually huh actually this is a problem
I've heard about is that like people who
make porn ads on the Internet yeah
they'll just grab any photo yeah without
any permission because like who are you
gonna do about it they'll grab a photo
of a totally wholesome pretty girl from
Instagram and then put her on pornhub
like [ __ ] hawk local cuties or tinder
they're like catfish people with some
buddies yeah that is so great that's
gotta be a no-no probably but but it's
like I'm like no way to do anything
about it yeah crazy damn I'm I got my
tumblr account and I have no access to
it yeah a tumble you're not tumblr yes
holy dude I used to upload my art and I
just forgot my password one day and it
was my old email account and I just have
no way to I mean tumblr is owned by
Yahoo so it's a [ __ ] mess yeah so
they locked me out you ever tried to get
back in is going on I tried your best
back in tamil dude wait how could you is
it linked to your yahoo account to my
old email which I don't have the
password - you were just [ __ ] your life
is yeah yeah it all over HeLa were you
gonna catch your brownie for that you
ever seen any word porn on tumblr on
your time there I did see like a like
randomly scrolling I remember all of
something like this porn I don't and I
didn't even know where it comes like as
a problem yeah that's an issue tumblr
get born it was so long ago I don't know
if it's still this manner yeah I think
it's always gonna be the same there's no
way of stopping why you know again like
the thing that I see on tumblr is this
furry porn have you seen that if I just
say I'm really glad that the episode you
start talking about furry porn on a
minute that I have to be on I mean do
you want to participate in this
conversation skit oh we're in it no
we're in it let's [ __ ] it because like I
that's the thing that I just I don't
have the empathy as a human being to
understand
I don't relate on an emotional base like
you what you have I don't know if you
guys have ever seen
Baroni or furry porn but it's drawings
of humanoid animals hmm with massive
[ __ ] I never said come Fest NASA just
don't get it okay
I don't let them eyes each other okay
romantic Lisa well if their lives are
not harming you okay you don't use
tumblr but somehow that's the stuff you
do see on tumblr yeah yeah [ __ ] oh no
well I've used it to the extent where
I'm like alright alright
roni roni sodomy I'm telling you you
don't have to [ __ ] try that should
all right look Jack is mr. inclusive
he's gonna stand up for [ __ ]
everybody so I'm not even gonna try to
go I mean you're allowed to have your
opinion I just I mean it doesn't I don't
see it so I'm just gonna look I mean I
mean you're welcome to live your life
and I'm not I'm not gonna tell you don't
but I also on one hand need to
acknowledge that that's [ __ ] bizarre
like we can acknowledge like dude keep
doing your thing love what you're doing
but also what the [ __ ] right like we can
build have both minds about it right I
guess you can alright whatever part of
that isn't part of the roadmap this
isn't on your flowchart you know but I
mean if that's what you're into
maybe that's what people think what does
that mean you want to [ __ ] animals no
that's that's the thing about it
it's like there's so much like intricacy
to it mmm it's like no I just want to
[ __ ] somebody else who's dressed as an
animal so don't want to [ __ ] and what I
don't want to because yeah because in
the cartoons they are they're not
dressed as animal they'll are animals
right and they have giant horse [ __ ]
that it you know what I'm saying
what I mean if you're gonna draw
yourself you might as well throw
yourself at the giant horse [ __ ] but
there are also horses yeah okay I mean I
agree to me not hired I don't get it
thank you I'm not I don't my mom like
holding you did
for a book club tail yeah we can no
that's a fascinating thing I mean if
you've never seen it go check it out on
tumblr because it's [ __ ] wild right
it's a wild ride
yeah account on tumblr brownie
Ashley brownie experience on Tuesday
we're doing that episode yeah and I'm
this week I'm gonna show you brownie
porn on tumblr and we'll report back on
Tuesday okay great please text me if you
want to look in the bottle and if you
want to call in I love to do I'll come
back for a second episode of the podcast
a brownie follows we make it like a book
club interesting stuff really so I love
this or it's just so interesting that I
mean your your channel got its first big
break from a pewdiepie contest right mhm
that's an accurate statement yeah I have
this clip it's really short it's crazy
that this is just the small little shout
out cool okay oh you're actually gonna
show this shout out oh my god man I
don't think it's embarrassing anything
it's really short [ __ ] I don't even
know this he doesn't even he doesn't
even show you he just said it yeah oh
look at you in the corner that's me
Oh almost unrecognisable dance sweet
baby boy how old were you at this time
uh 2013 so five years ago only three
mm-hm
cool okay the mother [ __ ] die don't
even know this guy seems crazy I really
like that's ever it is he's doing yeah
really funny his name is jacksepticeye
you should check him out he said it
jacksepticeye I feel well here's the
thing because there's huge
misconceptions about that because it's
easy to look back and me and Felix are
friends and everything I look back and
say like oh that's how he became popular
that's the secret
you just get a shout out competition but
at that time I was at two point two K
subs there and then after that I came
home from college and it was at 15,000
some friends which is [ __ ] bananas at
that moment and then after like 3 days I
went up to 20 K and then completely
stopped
mm nothing happened after that
interesting and I've been doing like
Grand Theft Auto five videos twice a day
for like a week and no one was watching
those either so the people who came from
the shoutout kind of watched one video
and I got like 15k views and then just
didn't watch anything else and then
people just stopped subscribing
it went for my getting three thousand
subs a day to a hundred right and then
it's like no one really watched anymore
so that that was that was the moment
where I changed like everything I was
doing in truth then I became more of
myself and just like settled into the
content mm-hmm so how long after the
shout out was it like what's the
timeline of the growth of your channel
like in comparison is how long did it
how much time pass from that shoutout to
the point where your channel started
like picking up traction about six
months I'd say so it was after that that
was September 2013 mm-hm and then after
that like the rest of the year passed
and nothing was really happening some
stuff was still like residual and
everything but I just like put my foot
down I started doing videos like much
harder much better a lot more variety I
wasn't just doing the same game anymore
the whole top of the morning thing
became like a huge thing at that point
and then it was August 2014 that the
channel hit a million subs so it was
like right after that nothing really
happened but it was the thing that
instigated the passion in me right so I
was like well here's this opportunity I
thought it would make the channel huge
and then it kind of died out real quick
and I was like okay well I need to do
something I need to like that's you know
that is what that's the beautiful thing
if anyone can get a shout out yeah like
it happens all the time but not
everybody takes that yeah and shout out
it into an opportunity shout out alone
doesn't get you to know yeah yeah and
Felix that 26 million subscribers at
that point that I don't same how [ __ ]
he just phenol is yeah I gave him back
then he was like yeah so like five years
later and I'm like six behind there yeah
I'm like if you told that kid that that
was going to happen he would have lost
his [ __ ] mind
ya know but I think that that's the
testament it's easy to be like oh you
got a shout out from PewDiePie you know
of course he's got 20 million but like
the shout-out is literally it's just
like a little like it's like this yeah a
little I mean it's important but like
yeah you have
to take and the analogy I always use is
like your channels your care Felix is
the key turning it on get you going
teaches you how to like drive it or
whatever but you're the one who has to
like change gears and stay in lane and
drive down the fly the way that shadow
wasn't that epic either no it was like
very lightweight if you go through
there's a there's a couple of other
channels who he shouted out in that and
there was another channel called
illmatic I remember who I thought was
phenomenal because of his editing at the
time was insane mm-hm and he's
Australian and he got up to like 11k
sobs and then never went any more
yeah I don't know what his channels at
now I hope he's doing well film addict
shut up but are you getting a shout out
bro shouting getting a [ __ ] shout
outs all day I know it was that kind of
thing where I'm like well I want this to
work so I want to like put the effort in
and get it going and yeah see how far I
can push it mm-hmm
and to get a shout out you can't have to
be put into work in already like he
wouldn't have shouted me out if I wasn't
doing two videos a day at that point
anyway
yeah was there a point where you were
getting feedback and you're like oh [ __ ]
they like what I'm doing because I
remember I had a moment like that were
you like oh [ __ ] something I'm doing
something right do you remember a
specific moment yeah I think it was
fairly early on people obviously like
the accent a lot but they liked the
energy and the enthusiasm B did you kick
it up at one point we're I mean because
like you said that you took these six
months and you really focus on your
content there's something you changed
where people were like oh that that's
good dumar that it was just a case of
being more of myself because at that
point I was trying to imitate like the
Marek's and the Felix and everybody else
he was kind of doing Let's Plays at that
point and then after that I was like
well I'm not gonna get anywhere from
somebody else that already has a channel
right so I just started being more of
who I am and talking honestly and saying
one is really healthy dude [ __ ] not to
take away from it I'm hugely grateful
for the shout-out Felix did know you and
I'm really glad that it happened and I
would never take that back I just think
there's some misconceptions online of
what that did sure and that's why
everyone's like you need to do a shout
out competition now because Felix did
one you can see it being a little
frustrating of being like you owe
everything to this one shot it's like
well that's really not
what happened yeah and even Felix like
recently came to me he was like do you
want to like delete those videos off our
channels like still a whole thing
because he even he knew that people were
like [ __ ] on me for that and saying
like you're only popular because of this
thing so that's so insane
keep it there it's a piece of history
but it no it's good yeah leave you go
and watch it you can see it's like he's
not like you need to go subscribe right
now play your video it was like check
the guy out and he I think he was
supposed to do the shared our
competition and then he kind of forgot
about it and then he did it really quick
cuz he came back from somewhere and then
that's why his face isn't even on it cuz
he just recorded the thing with his mic
unbelievable man PewDiePie you what a
guy guys on no level yeah he still are
you've know that we talked about like
burnout and [ __ ] he's still posting
every [ __ ] okay I don't know how he
does it
he must be deeply deeply I mean he Polly
damaged and miserable really
well-adjusted that's what pisses me off
the motor
raw damage man I mean he changes up his
content enough to keep it fresh for
himself so yeah I don't like how
well-adjusted he seems I don't like it
was just a psychopath and he doesn't
care about anything that's what I like
the top where worst what's the top of
the morning what's going on there
where'd that come from
oh well if you if you go back and watch
an earlier video my intro used to be
hello all you beautiful people out there
yeah the top of them how it was like I
wanted yeah I wanted to have like
somebody else's voice made mine I hated
my accent I didn't like myself or
anything so my earlier videos have a
different intro different voice no face
cam and then later on like during that
time I was like whoa I don't really like
this and I start showing my face and
then everyone thought I was American
pretending to be Irish
because me doing that phenomenally
sounded kind of Americanized right and
then I was like well I want to show
people I'm Irish what's the most Irish
thing you can say and then an episode of
friends
Monica says topper died morning to you
laddies
very Irish and that was like okay I'll
be as Irish as I can be in the first
five seconds of my video just as a joke
that's [ __ ] I was like if you don't
make the first five seconds of the video
you're not gonna like the rest of [ __ ]
off Great Firewall yeah I'm sorry so I
can't really take credit for friends a
lot of generations of Irish people came
up with that how do you uh are you
famous in Ireland cuz like do you get
recognized more you're the biggest
youtuber in Ireland do you get
recognized people know about you and
Ireland yeah they do
buddies you say like that why do you say
like that because when I was living in I
was living in a small town that had like
15,000 people in it yeah like every time
I went outside it was like six really
yeah Wow Plus cuz it's a small town and
people know you lived there and people
are just out and about anyway depending
on the time of day obviously I went had
green hair it was just are you born of a
minute in Ireland you're bono famous and
I'm pretty like household name on every
President of Ireland pretty much yeah I
think probably president level well
what's it's funny cuz a thing that
happened a while ago was they did a list
of the top 10 most influential Irish
people in like a tabloid paper it meant
nothing but at number 10 was the
president and nine was Bono and then I
was next you to you're done you're all
in this so it's really weird that's not
that is not Horne was right after me
House like hey now how do I wish people
feel about about you are they like are
they like hey one of our boys you know
what I mean what's the mentality like
it's very divided really large people
can be the most passive-aggressive
people you'll ever meet they're super
friendly and they're great right but to
be like anytime somebody it's II like
the thing about Irish people was like
you'd see somebody like at a person in
LA would see somebody's like big house
in the hill and they'd be like wow
that's what I'm gonna work towards or an
Irish person but I call [ __ ] doing
well for himself isn't he all right
and then you never talk to her anything
that's a really fine thing so Meyers
people are like yeah he's out there
representing the country and other
people are like I hate that he
represents our country
I'm like I'm not represented [ __ ]
anything just I can't even represent
myself yeah what what are ya that's so
if you go like how much are you getting
recognized here in LA is compared to
like back in Ireland
not nearly the same really but you got
the green hair too yeah
I expected the opposite to be frank
really well I don't know because like
ela I mean probably the biggest
challenge Israel all right
most famous youtuber okay I don't know
but in Israel and no one nobody there's
no one really Bob well also I think it's
the language barrier probably yeah you
speaking Hebrew yeah
English obviously that's why we speak -
I thought we were speaking Hebrew all
this time
do you remember was there a time we're
like cuz your channel at least from my
recollection seemed to like blow up
really fast right yeah was there like a
month or like a period of time where you
went from making like you know a couple
hundred bucks to like all the sudden
your income was like insane yeah it went
from earning just enough to like get by
each week to a point where as it was
like go write an apartment move out of
my parents place and just in like what
scope of time in like a month it was
like [ __ ] crazy yeah but I mean at
the time yeah it was it was nuts it was
like the difference between like a
hundred dollars a month to like six and
a half thousand and I was like I can
move out yay I can actually rent a place
what were you doing before you two you
had a job we're going to college what
where did you see yourself going before
they had this whole opportunity
I went I've gone to college twice really
so I ran to college from music
production first and things like that it
wasn't very good at it I play drums and
I wanted to learn more about that but it
was all about like theory and how to fix
electrical circuits and [ __ ] like that
and I didn't care yeah so I left that
and then became very depressed and
miserable at home that's when I started
YouTube and then went back to college
for hotel management Oh
and graduated from Hotel College I did
yeah how many years is that which I'll
call it three years
you're a [ __ ] hotel manager bro
bitrates when did you learn that
hotel management [ __ ] all you learn how
horrible hotels are the whole time we
were there that were like hotels are
overworked underpaid understaffed and
they're all losing money and we're like
cool I'll get my daily effect that's so
weirdly specific I don't know you can't
learn that so in in college when I was
doing like the final semester that's
when that moment happened and I was like
I left college wants before I should
finish this one out and get a degree of
some sort I don't know where YouTube's
going mm-hm and thankfully it took off
cuz I booked a hotel yeah and you were
living with your parents yeah how did
your parents feel about the YouTube
pursuit I mean my parents are always
kind of been supportive they're good
almost to a fault they're one of the
good ones yeah well I to a fault
I don't think you should give him that
much credit right it was just the case
of like whatever I was into they would
just let me do and if I was passionate
about it they were do you think if you
were like now still at five thousand
subs at home being a youtuber what would
they would they still be like do your
thing or would they be like you need to
[ __ ] off push out I'd say they'd be fine
damn what a good one that's pretty
interesting
yeah damn different nice people sorry
you're gonna open your own hotel now
what's the first what's the first nice
thing you bought when you started
getting that cheddar cheese at guacamole
I bought an iPad Mini
that was the first nice time watch game
grumps video is in bed mm-hmm I used to
watch them everyday but it was on my
computer I'm like I want to watch it I
didn't have a like a smartphone at that
point I was like I want to watch them in
bed so I bought an iPad Mini was like
six hundred euro I was like way too
[ __ ] much like well I even get the
use out and I went over in like a month
in my head being like should I get it i
man I don't know then I got it news that
every night thank God I still have it
yeah yeah you use it I don't use it yeah
yeah a little remembering the first
thing we bought I remember the first
time we bought nice was the TV
we're in new york new york i bought like
a 35 inch TV
I was like I never I never wanted never
had it in like five years and I was like
I like listen I had a pretty good month
I buy myself a TV hell yeah
drop that cheddar on it it was a bill
actually wasn't the one in the podcast
studio so we replace it yeah you got rid
of your own piece of memorabilia yeah
well you gave it to your family someone
took it
Ian's got it oh yeah um until now you
know I want my [ __ ] TV but it was
funny though our bedroom was tiny and
the TV was big New York apartment yeah
and I wanted a big TV dude I was
crushing it looks like 500 bucks by like
Sian like it was only the bed in the TV
I mean it's a smaller than yeah I mean
it was small I mean what place is much
much this is like 65 or smaller it was
much smaller but like I watched we
watched a lot of hits matter x hunter oh
yeah dude first time watching that mm
banger I thought everybody was an anime
I say listen you gotta watch hunter x
hunter people don't listen to me
people need to listen to me more this is
your moment shout it out trying to tell
everybody hunter advocate I'm a super
fan oh really
are you do I mean what's your favorite
anime I don't know cuz I already got
into anime like very reason I mean I
watched like Dragonball when I was
younger in have you watched Hunter x
Hunter no I know of it and has a legacy
to it but you said it like you've
watched it now I know it's I know it's
probably decent it's not a decent give
me a [ __ ] break
come anime I didn't mean to [ __ ]
attack okay go right you're a brony but
what do you like what do you watch my
forever is one punch man oh just okay
one punch is probably my favorite oh
it's his favorite like I've watched it
three times
he wants to re-watch it boy like every
week every week you ask me do you want
to watch one punch man like oh that was
gone is why did yes okay good I have I
don't have to leave this table but I
don't want to really watch the whole
season ten times I love it so much that
I bought it on Amazon a
so that I could watch it with the
English dub so they have felt newer
because I've watched it so many times
was it [ __ ] no I loved it in English
yeah it's pretty good I guess I'm
getting used to
yeah but yeah but even to got announced
yeah I just like it it's well animated
the pace it's amazing great it's a it's
got it's like a perfect show it's it's
doesn't take itself seriously ela it's
hilarious have you yeah you see what is
wrong it's a short yeah you're in the
minority here yeah I watched like three
times - oh yeah thanks daddy I'm not
even that much of a superfan yeah he's
in the minority of friends in this
hooking it's so perfect it's like it's
hilarity that the fighting scenes are
the best I've ever seen
yeah so well animated doesn't take
itself seriously compelling characters
incredible action non-stop thrill rides
while maintaining a great heightened
sense of humor all at the same time that
I mentioned great animation yeah yeah
well I can't wait come out under like
one punch man is not the best that's
actually attack on Titan okay I hate to
admit this but I feel like all my
favorite shows right now or anime it's
because there's good Agra Duke oh no
it's like they didn't want on Netflix
now if the little cat girl who gets
Anglo I haven't watched that I've seen
is that a good one yeah I'll check it
out it's funny I mean I saw that the
picture I was like I can't I'm not
really my what about my hero academia
we're watching you want to get the
superhero right now he's my hero
academia if I am [ __ ] every Saturdays
on Hulu I'm like Mila clear our calendar
I have to say the fight scene but - I
don't want I'm not gonna spoil anything
but like that Epic's fight scene between
one of the newer ones yeah that's with
all my lessons the villain yeah yeah oh
my god dude I was like I've so
captivated yeah I watched that episode
back-to-back twice that's the good one
I know any boku no hero fans out there
yeah um but I love all these shows but
Hunter hunter by far I mean but in terms
of like writing and music I mean the the
writing and that show is is beyond
anything I've ever seen it how long is
it it's it's like 550 ups there's animes
like like one piece oh I will never
[ __ ] dare to get into because it has
like 5000 episode and it's still going
like take a rest least watch bleach and
then it was like try nothing is I try
it's never getting to the end
give me a break dude I need to know that
there's an end in sight yeah that's why
I'm like full metal full metal there
broke down series that's my second
favorite yeah my comment on that that
one the first anime series we watched
and I loved it mmm and I tried
rewatching it recently after becoming a
fan of like you know one punch man and
and and Hunter x Hunter and I'm like
don't love it as much the original or
Brotherhood though we watched both other
hoods obviously you know the more
cherished one yeah the good one yeah I
don't know that was a good judgment
though cuz I think you only tried like
to it like just at the beginning
yeah pretty slow yeah yeah I guess so I
still think it's up there yeah did the
tap what's the tax rate in Ireland let's
get to what's really important it's like
15% isn't it it's like 12 and a half
corporate tax oh my god that's what you
pay cuz you're probably incorporated
right yeah well I'm not anymore
oh so you're getting [ __ ] by UK now
was that a big change for you because
that Ireland has like one of the lowest
tax rates of any what is it in the UK
it's probably up there with everywhere
else like 40 yawn or something yeah I
think it's 40 to 40 I don't say out loud
because I can't remember it off stop my
head but it's it's like much more yeah
was that a big change for you yeah
that's kind of painful I mean well it's
also just you have to go through all the
[ __ ] paperwork of moving everything
over and that is so annoying so you had
to change your company to an English
company or her
that work yeah there was just a lot of
[ __ ] involved with it like creating like
subsidiaries and [ __ ] like that just to
make sure everything was above board
God I have fantasies about paying 15%
tax raise I wake up that's insane like
oh my god our tax bill and kitchen were
set well here it's like closer to 50
yeah in California just a prep you if
you want to move to LA you're gonna be
paying 50% okay I'll keep that in mind
man start saving up now saving up for
that tax bill can't wait to pay that
army bill I mean 50 percent that's where
you're facing here I mean that's that's
what's ridiculous about it right cuz we
you don't really get much yeah yeah
exactly no health care yeah that's a
whole rabbit hole that's the thing
because my editor is from Sweden and
everything over there is free so like
free health care free education you get
paid to go to college I don't forget all
these that's like a conservative talking
point here is there like socialism never
works and it's like what are you talking
about nor Scandinavia's like utopia I
mean it works there's social programs
it's not a [ __ ] country no
apparently no far I mean no I wouldn't
say so but um I mean well you people you
probably don't want to get an apology
debate because I'm I'm not thinking
about politics I'm just a person
experiencing like paying so much taxes
but you don't get anything I don't know
even why it's gotta be so political well
it's like I mean I guess the thing that
I've been thinking Trump wanted to have
a hundred million dollar military parade
in DC and meanwhile actual veterans are
getting health care yeah it's like what
the [ __ ] meanwhile it's like you always
get this talking point of like how are
you gonna pay for it you say you know
it's a very liberal talking point that
you want you know health care and
college tuition free to ever want it and
they would say how are you gonna pay for
it it's like bro you how you gonna pay
for your hundred million dollar
look military prey space force damn let
it out man you know be cure truth how
are you gonna pay for anything spill
that political worry we're in debt
trillions of dollars what do you who's
paying for that I don't know how
everyone yes you don't figure it out no
they think it won't be the truth of the
matter is that when you have social
health care it's actually cheaper than
what the [ __ ] everywhere have we have
now because like well anyway you have to
drop a sound board under now to break
that tonight it's true what else do you
have
are these new just got your stream decks
yeah that's Alex Jones here this is my
favorite you're gonna like this yeah
[Music]
they had the curb theme every time I die
in fortnight really yeah you like curb
yeah me too I've watched out a whole lot
of it what I've seen is good
yeah it's great you watch Seinfeld no is
it popular in Ireland it's popular
everywhere right it was like it came
right before my time and then growing up
friends was like the big thing yeah so I
kind of missed the Seinfeld boat but I
do want to go back and watch it I
recommend it first a few episodes on why
you like Diane yeah Mike's iPhone um you
how many tattoos you do you have just
one just the one I want to get a second
one this here I'll show the people here
you have a massive blood we have you
actually can show it like just yeah you
don't need a picture here it is on the
TV if you guys with director have you
guys look on the TV here there it is wow
it's so the likeness is uncanny what
what does the game mean to you that you
are so enthused about this game that you
were you wanted to tattoo it what is it
again to people like me I'm not
blood-borne okay Dan's a big fan of it
apparently yeah
so I well I've always kind of been a
from software the people who make it and
I love dark souls i love Dark Souls 2 3
demon souls and this and then I always
wanted to get a tattoo anyway and it was
in my head like what
[ __ ] am I gonna get nothing really means
a whole lot to me and then this this I
decided to get because you have you
don't need to know a blood-borne is to
know what this is I think it's just a
cool design anyway I was like well I
want to make the leap and get something
and then it's like my second favorite
game of all time what's first Shadow of
the Colossus well let's get a fat [ __ ]
tell you a some getting it here oh my
face well I don't know you love it that
much more I've never played that game
but it looks amazing you've seen footage
it's so good
nice I played it when I was a teenager
and it blew me away when you poop do you
do you wipe forward or backwards front
to back front to back see what boast
about you go like this yeah okay what do
you do
listen it's a whole thing but eyes but I
know I go [ __ ] I go back to front I
go under the balls and I and so it's
really a point of contention contention
here on this podcast but [ __ ] weird
so if you drag [ __ ] into your balls bro
I what if you drag [ __ ] up your ass
crack then you can just keep wiping what
do you yeah that's weird I have control
Doug I'm weird you street [ __ ] up your
ass crack all the way off control dude
all the way up the back leave a good
sense or do you use baby wipes no you go
all dry yeah I mean if there's a if it's
a messy situation there's a sink nearby
you know I'll just like dab it up with
your hand no with the toilet paper to go
wrong with because I well because I
can't wet toilet paper cuz if my
[ __ ] hairy and it sticks to the hair
and gets dingleberries but you have a
class [ __ ] sounds like [ __ ] you
problem man no I mean shake your ass
deep save your ass I mean a little bit
yeah yeah you gotta keep things trimmed
but how do you safely shave your [ __ ]
with very precise tools what tell me
I've because I'm a man that needs to
learn I don't know man I don't know like
like Dollar Shave Club
could you use a razor no not that
[ __ ] we what that's what I'm
concerned about but I don't how maybe
you you you you you you manicure with
scissors or what I mean whatever
whatever gets the job done
whatever's in the house hedge clippers
lawn mower huh you know so you don't use
a razor and get in there no Jesus that's
what I that's what I imagine but the
thing is even if the [ __ ] are short
I feel like good well feel like it's
still good all right well I mean the
situation is clearly different look that
I could just be lying right now as well
I'm dragging you down a rabbit hole
you're not lying I'm not like no here
yeah shaven no I just I'd have thought
never crossed my mind to be frank with
you I know I actually had guests here
who they shaved their [ __ ] to to help
the situation now there and I have to
think that would be a huge life
improvement for me yeah but I don't
really know how to get in there do you
put a mirror on the ground do you lay on
your back and look at your ass hole in
the mirror mean how do you do it how do
you get the value get the vantage point
I think you just guess you guess it's
like what so like this
do you've a [ __ ] prolapsed ass oh but
like hemorrhoids stick it out I don't
know it just seems like a more delicate
job than just you know his landlady get
it watches wow that's [ __ ] just take a
page out of Philly DS book and just jump
in he seems like a clean I'm fascinated
by this because everyone says this is
something that you know generally isn't
talked about but everyone has it really
no we need to be positive male role
models right now yeah half my audience
are freaking out right now I didn't need
to know yes you did fanfic just got a
whole lot weirder I didn't say that
oh god I just give people ideas one
thing that I did pick up from having
this conversation I'd like to pass on to
you and actually some of our listeners
who are probably waiting for updates
Metamucil have you heard of that it's a
fiber supplement made of this thing
called Basilian husks and it really
tightens your your [ __ ] yeah
hmm and so I found that it's really it's
been a great really great beautiful
thing take a pop with a couple of those
in your mouth fiber it's supposed to be
forever died it was just balanced you
wouldn't be slurry colic oh hell I mean
sure but it helped it helped even euros
all the time and euros you're not
familiar most Nava cartels that we
shouldn't like a dream burger again
burger in burrito sauce you know it's
also doesn't help you do Irish people
[ __ ] with spicy food no actually I do
what do you mean Ireland like what's the
dish that like people [ __ ] with their
yeah we don't we don't really have like
traditional dishes that down a law suits
in here yeah are we covered by insurance
no I'm bleeding everywhere right
no like lamb stew is like a big thing or
Shepherd my lamb stew that sounds dank
it's pretty good really fatty cut of
lamb yeah what's shepherd's pie I'm not
sure I've ever had it's like minced meat
with certain like we've had that over
like mashed potatoes yeah mashed
potatoes on top no and top you open
cocaine so it's like crispy on top damn
pie crust on the top
no that's American oh yeah I've got
something they were doing melted cheese
on top yeah okay quick cream right cool
now I'm hungry shitty ass yeah I need
help need help I'm not and let me tell
you what I'm not doing all right for
anybody are you supposed to be his carer
what are you Ryan like and made of
intestines and oh my lord potent blood
puddin well yeah you [ __ ] with blood
pudding hell yeah
black black pudding I've smile a turd
blood that you eat basically spices in
it she's going to tank ugly or unhealthy
Oh woefully unhealthy I'd say mmm salts
but it's so good that it's worth it yeah
put it on it's like a fire spray
couldn't think of a better and like more
enticing name well it's called black
puddin
oh it's not blood put in no that's that
is what it is but we don't call it that
because no one would eat that yeah
that's about weird
I mean you eat sausages which is lying
but like ya know do you have well we've
got pretty much everything sorted okay
we got through the the sodomy the
furries the politics we dropped a
fortnight in there alright yeah I'll put
four tie in the thumbnail we talked
about design fall and therapy Logan Paul
we talked about the suicide forest yeah
oh wait who's gonna wait fight drop that
in there August 25th we didn't talk
about that no no no look man I have
talked about oh we know this podcast
today not today
who do you think is gonna win I think
Logan's gonna win really hmm
is he taller does he have a longer reach
it makes you think that yeah yeah he's
taller he just seems like he's bigger
Carter he's probably way more weighs
more you months like no case I he's like
stacked and everything and he'd got into
great shape but watching him fight jo
weil or it was like well you only won
cuz Jo didn't really fight and I haven't
I haven't seen that actual fight so that
would be good to him for my opinion but
a lot of times in boxing and fighting in
general the bigger guy generally wins I
mean that's why you have weight classes
but these guys are probably not in the
same way matter Tyson yes well Tyson but
they were in the same weight class he
was heavy it was South's yeah that's
true right
yeah but Tyson was also like a [ __ ]
monster I just think just physicality
will win out and right Logan used to do
like wrestling in college and high
school and stuff and so I'm always
leaning towards chaos I simply because
he had already had a fight
maybe but from what it sounds like not
that valuable of experience but what I
do think is that it's gonna be fairly
boring cuz they're not professional
fighters it's gonna go the whole length
nobody's gonna get knocked out and
somebody's gonna win on on a technical
win yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be
something less oh we were wrong
hopefully someone gets like money round
one knockout I'll watch that I'm gonna
watch the highlights I'm wash the [ __ ]
out of the highlights oh you're not
gonna get to ten dollar pay-per-view is
it
ten bucks that was like 11 days I don't
know what it is $10 paper pay-per-view
doesn't pay the bills come on that's a
lot hundred thousand people watching
yeah they're gonna charge I honestly
have no idea I don't know what's going
on with that um yeah well [ __ ] that we
should just put money into a pot and see
who wins that pays the bills if you're
good at it yeah so we've pretty yeah I
mean we've really covered every single
thing oh I was wondering that people are
very religious in Ireland right yeah are
you religious no I've been religious
since I was like 12
you should be an altar boy though really
yeah what happened did you just like I
mean was there something or you're just
like yeah not for me
yeah I forgot it was so weird I was such
a [ __ ] woke 12 year old really I was
like running down the video playing
around and then I just thought to myself
for the contrary existencial was like
what if it's not real huh what if God is
not up there what if God is not one of
us and then I like went down this rabbit
hole I was like I don't think I believe
in God anymore on by on your own kind of
yes your own thing
are you lose your family religious yeah
oh my god they think about your are you
an atheist would you consider yourself
an atheist or an agnostic or you just
not your yeah would you say I'd say more
agnostic more for the optimism of it
sure where atheism is like no nothing
exists my agnostic is like something
might exist who knows open up my eyes to
it yeah
God isn't real changed my mind Yeah
right exactly
how does your family feel about your
godlessness my my my parents never
really cared they didn't mind they went
to church and everything but I never
told my grandmother that I didn't
believe in God because she was very very
religious and and I'd never knock
anybody who is like if you wanted to do
me there it gave her like great peace of
mind and she felt a lot closer to things
in her later years and everything so
fantastic but for me it just didn't
really make sense in my fists in hmm as
they're growing like among younger
people that's probably a growing
attitude there 100% yeah I mean we're
just legalized abortion there a couple
of months ago right and that's crazy
just a couple months ago
yeah Wow ironically America's gonna be
going back through making it illegal I
mean that's huge for Ireland I like
same-sex marriages allowed there now and
that was a recent development to write
that yeah that was what that was with in
the time I've been doing YouTube I
remember them maybe like two years ago
great Arlen's moving forward the whole
world is mm-hmm it's a we're saying that
well it's not that weird it makes sense
but it's just interesting hmm look how
we talked about religion sex life [ __ ]
how's yours yeah that's not good what
does that mean now I want now let's get
into what's your relationship like with
your parents fine whenever they come
back how's your sex life you brought it
up as a [ __ ] meme right
long story I get it
you have a girlfriend right
swords she's into you I mean why me as a
girlfriend now as well yeah no I don't
have a girlfriend
anytime what I don't have any I mean not
together although I I mean foul sorcery
girl yeah I have to worry quite
impossible
oh well also add to the mix that nobody
wants to [ __ ] that maybe would make it
even more of a Pete there's some people
out there some people in the comments
right now being like I would definitely
[ __ ] you yeah they're not out there I'm
telling you it's cuz you're like married
like very public publicly and you so you
think if you're not a single public
would want to [ __ ] me [ __ ] maybe fanfic
it's an idea I write one for you that be
saying not about me but I'll just in
general I write one actually I did it I
forgot
I said I've noticed you said in a video
that 2017 was the worst of your life
that really stuck out to me I was like
whoa I don't know if you don't want to
talk about that but I was really curious
like what was going on 2017
there's a lot of stuff a lot of like
YouTube stuff and everything trying to
figure out what I wanted to do like that
thing of like climbing the hill and then
getting there and be like what else can
I do it now
yeah and feeling very aimless there was
a lot of like like stuff with people in
my life that had changed very
drastically a lot of friendships a lot
of stuff like that that had just gotten
very weird and then by the end of the
year I was I just felt so drained and
exhausted miserable mmm I didn't really
know what was going on and that's why
the whole like PMA thing started because
I I was going into this year I was like
I'm gonna make it positive I'm gonna
change my mentality and just work
towards a better me so what is PMA mean
positive mental attitude and what is
that
it's just something that kind of gets
thrown around to be like keep a positive
mental attitude and to me it was
something that I could just keep saying
to like remind myself to be happier like
a mantra something yeah that's it not to
dwell on the [ __ ] that was happening
that really meant nothing in the grand
scheme of things and then because I kept
saying it a whole bunch my audience
obviously picked up on it and then it's
become like a whole like a movement on
my channel mm-hmm I was like okay I can
now we can wear it around with me so you
feel that you were you were able to
wilfully change your attitude by just
consciously forcing yourself to be more
positive not exactly because I don't I
don't think that's healthy just and that
was the whole point of it I was worried
that people would be like yes go out
there and be happy if you're happy then
nothing gets you down so what's the
[ __ ]
I appreciate this more complex yeah it's
about like it's gonna sound so hokey
it's about like trying your best to get
to a positive putting in the work to get
out of the hole yeah so for me it was a
lot of like starting to go to therapy
like reflecting on things easing up on
my work life and just having a better
balance with my mental health and coming
to terms because for the longest time I
was like everyone sees me as the
positive person but if I show any sign
of like I'm sad then I was worried that
was letting people down and then I
creates anxiety and
yeah things like that so I was like okay
I'm just gonna be open honest cuz I'm
going crazy it's gotta be a burden to be
like that positive happy energetic guy
yeah and then especially when you have
people coming to you be like man there's
like no drama on you and you're so happy
all the time I mean you have nice things
to say about you all the time that's
just way too much pressure for any
person Hank and it's not true I don't
feel like I'm not that all the time
everyone's perfect yeah so then just
know trying to reconfigure my brain
again I should get to a better place and
because it was a lot of stuff that was
like that meant nothing with a lot of
very tiny things that kind of buildup
that mean nothing and then you get
miserable about them for no reason mhm
and then because I have so many people
come to me talking about their mental
health all the time I figured that let's
do something better with it that's why
we start doing the monthly charity
streams and then this is like the
hashtag for it every time and try and
turn it turn some turn things into a
positive I think trying to work to a
better life god bless I was I'm an
energy to be miserable sadly no I'm in
the same headspace you are I really like
what you said it's not about like hey
I'm happy now yeah it's about you have
to make you have to like make the
changes that you know you need to make
yeah to get there and I think a lot of
youtubers suffer with that because they
have everything they need technically or
everything they've always wanted you
know it's like why it's like I have no
reason and yeah
worst of all a lot of the fans or people
watch are like very judgmental about
like what the [ __ ] do you have to
complain about and that's the thing when
you're when your finances are taken care
of and you your own boss and you're
doing a job you love all that's left is
emotional issues all the things that you
have left to worry about are stuff
that's all in here and your brain
there's a lot of [ __ ] to you that is not
useful at all and and on top of that
millions of people have an opinion about
you that you've never met yeah and you
have to be their advocate for their
mental health a lot of the time as well
and keeping make sure they're
entertained and keeping a check on them
and making sure people are okay mm-hm
that's why like after a while it gets
you but yeah it's nobody can go out
there and just be like okay I would be
happy today
yeah because you're a [ __ ] psychopath
if you do that yeah but as long as
you're trying like if you have a [ __ ]
day it's fine sit in the [ __ ] day allow
yourself to feel [ __ ] get it out of your
system and move on to the next day
mm-hmm if that [ __ ] keep going
mm-hmm if you have a [ __ ] month a [ __ ]
year keep going
mm-hmm eventually that day will arrive
where you're happier and at all like
that's the thing everyone always says
like people get bullied in high school
and then they grow up it's like yeah
that really meant nothing did it yeah I
mean leave some scars if it's bad enough
but then at the end of the day it's like
no you kept going you kept fighting
mm-hmm and you're at a better place in
your life mm-hmm god bless I love it
no I've been I've been seriously I've
been like I've been legitimately
depressed for like probably two years
and never just now I'm starting to like
address it hmm and that's part of why
we're not posting videos on h3 cuz we
were just doing too much [ __ ] and I was
like working every day and like was
getting between me and ela and you work
from home as well hobbies yeah exactly
your free time and your leisurely time
are mixed up cuz you work from home and
it's just so bad yeah you know you can
only take it for so long before you're
like I'm just gonna have I'm I'm just
gonna disappear forever or I'm gonna
address this and that's the I think
that's the problem with youtubers is
that when you're on that treadmill and
you're constantly working towards it you
feel like if you fall off you're never
gonna be able to get back on again it's
really not true no it's not and you can
see channels like Shane Dawson who was
had like huge popularity a few years ago
kind of he didn't disappear or anything
but it's definitely not jelly yeah yeah
and I was [ __ ] huge again yeah the
biggest he's ever been yeah same with
Phil Edie he was big went down that was
huge again I mean the one that's that's
great well those guys stayed active the
one that always blows a mine is jontron
like he doesn't even [ __ ] post a
video for a year you know what I mean
and he comes back and everybody's still
there no excited first content mm-hmm so
it's very much that that myth has been
busted yeah that's why a lot of more
youtubers are talking about it now it's
they feel like they can take a break but
I also when you take a break and it is
really hard to get back to it yeah
that's one thing that like when you're
in that treadmill like chase when you
post a video every week or at least
used to do once a week it's kind of like
it's just the routine and then once you
break it it's like even harder to get
back to it or the problem for us is that
you're always chasing like a feeling or
a time of like how it used to be yeah
instead of just embracing like all right
shit's different now mm-hmm you know and
I mean that's the same for the audience
the audience are still chasing the old
yeah and I think they they either mature
with you or they leave and [ __ ] all over
you yeah so you could have just I mean
you've been doing it for how long at
this point yeah
you're not even this a long time you
were yeah five years yeah you can every
person change it's like every three
years so yeah so I think part of what's
really important for us is just to be
like okay that that air is done like
it's a new it's a whole new era now we
would keep we've always been like man I
can't do this anymore but okay now I
really need to get back into doing that
again mm-hmm and then it's just like
this never-ending cycle yeah it's all
about finding balance any stuff that
makes you happy outside of your channel
as well that was like that was like the
thing talking to in therapy I realize
that I don't do anything outside my
channel I don't do anything like
physical everything's everything I do is
mental even if I play video games it's
still keeping your brain on you need
something to let your brain shut the
[ __ ] up every no good
that's not have anything a lot too
something up it's like a whole you need
a wholesome activity yeah to do just
distract you're in the [ __ ] real
world like dude what do you do do you
have any hobbies outside of working
games now that I've come here I've just
been hanging out with people a lot more
like living in Brighton I hadn't left my
house in like two weeks
cuz I don't need to I have to keep my
videos going and then when I came here I
finally had people to hang out with
day-to-day they're just been hanging out
with people all the time it's just
cleared my head completely nice well not
completely no no I wholly clear but yeah
compared to what it was I'm so much
happier and then it makes it easier to
get back into your videos and if if you
hate doing it the way you're doing then
that's the sign that something has to
change
yeah schedule changes or your
methodology changes or what you're
actually doing changes and the bottom
line is if you're not happy doing the
old ver
of you that the audience wants then it's
not worth doing so you might can't do it
you might as well do what makes you
happy and if the audience leaves they
leave if they stay they stay yeah you
gonna make yourself happy first it's a
tough pill to swallow but it's the truth
hmm and something a lot of people don't
want to swallow cut the tension now
we've really talked about everything we
really have except one thing ghost
stories [ __ ] yeah do you believe in
ghosts or UFOs or anything paranormal
like that I want to I'm too rational I
don't know it's fine it's a weird thing
like we we have a habit of asking all of
our guests if you have any ghosts or
UFOs for it sometimes the answer is
quite surprising but a lot of times they
say no and that's the end of it
okay so UFOs story I mean not really a
alien UFO but one time I was out when I
was like no like eight to ten years old
I was out in my backyard in Ireland and
we were all outside very late at night
in Ireland you can see all the stairs
because there's not much light pollution
going on and then all of a sudden my
friends were talking and I could hear
this like almost like a jet engine sound
and they kept getting louder and I like
looked up and there was a star in the
sky that just got like wider and
brighter and then vanished and all of a
sudden the sound was gone and I was like
that's it I was an alien dude I just saw
an alien huh how old real eight nine
did they see it no and I feel like a
lunatic everything I loved were you guys
here when they like the missile went off
the deer the jenna Marbles yeah oh and
we're the ones that somehow like capture
that moment yeah did you see it in the
air actually no I just saw it all over
the news I think we may have been in New
York at the time right all right
but it was it just turned out it was
some missile test yeah I'm sure you want
to see when you go outside yeah all
right
do you believe in ghosts and aliens I'm
don't believe there's aliens visiting
the earth yeah I don't believe in ghosts
I believe there's aliens they're out
there [ __ ] slamming away yeah but
microbes going at it killing it you know
but I don't think they're visiting there
I mean why would they want to I don't
know who knows imagine if they visited
the earth where where do you think is
like the worst place they could land to
be like [ __ ] this never coming here
again
that's a good question yeah cuz like
everyone's like oh the Komen they'll go
to like DC or New York like Independence
Day or something no they could end up in
like like Zanzibar some pretty much
anywhere is just a [ __ ] I mean to an
alien they're like what the [ __ ] is this
Danson San Bernardino they they land in
Greenland and there's just no one right
yeah this is weird no this is very
reputable burbank's the [ __ ] zero
there's a Sox there's nobody here
nothing's popping off the bars are at
Muscle Beach
I had a lot of fun meet you this is
great it was a wonderful beautiful time
I'm really glad we got the chance to sit
down and talk how did you think it was
gonna go well I think we're gonna I
thought it was gonna be so awkward
are you kidding no it's I know I thought
I know you're a great guy I met you
before your sweet [ __ ] guy every time
I meet you I'm on that guy's a [ __ ]
sweetheart say that so now I write my
fan fiction anthology I am still curious
about your [ __ ] manicuring techniques
of you know we talk about understand
you're gonna take that to the grave and
that's fine I do have a technique down
oh I'll show you well every razors you
can squirt your seed on my [ __ ] okay
dan keeps telling me to you guys
represent dot-com /h stage-three comes
in black and also he's got the hoodie
and also I'm not wearing the extra thick
hat but it's there too okay
they're great I did my duty I love them
thank you all thank you I mean oh you're
sold out and so that well you can still
buy them ah
there are in reorders Oh PMA oh you
Jerry can do a pre-order yeah okay just
this batches all down cool I'm very
happy about it that's awesome and you
guys this stuff was going great so good
for you
thank you thank you it's very popular I
see it everywhere what the teddy fresh
yeah I see it all over my time lines all
the time
that's really cool mmm freshen it you
guys should be very proud
I'm really excited we have some really
cool we've been working really hard on
tape fresh actually mostly what we've
been working on is Teddy fresh yeah and
we've worked in a lot of designs for
this winter and 2019 so it's gonna take
a while for it to come to fruition
yeah but very much looking forward to it
cool as long as you're excited about it
that's good long as you're having fun
all right guys
thank you so much for tuning in Thank
You Sean
of course thank you guys I'm glad I came
around catch catch Sean on tour at
jacksepticeye tours were calm or just
jacksepticeye calm jacksepticeye dot-com
slash tour I don't know what the link is
Oh get some t-shirts PMA yeah what's the
website st. Paul it's on the same gonna
do it all there really one-stop I got it
on lock fanfiction tab there yeah the
highest the highest rated one will get a
free shirt wow now that's what I call
positive what else next week who do we
have Bert that's correct
Bert Kreischer next week very excited
amazing rate the wonderful the hilarious
Bert Kreischer well that's Friday and
then we got a show Tuesday oh yeah
Tuesday we're gonna be broadcasting on
Tuesday current events talking about
everything going on because you need to
hear what I have to say because what
else are you gonna have an opinion right
should talk about buttholes more I talk
about it a lot alright that's about it
guys thank you so much for watching have
a great terrific weekend don't forget to
miss the new episode of my hero academia
check out this weekend hell yeah viewing
partners minute I think it's gonna be
good up so things are heating up yeah
and we will see you on Tuesday
so my dudes I wish you a blessed weekend
and all the greatest things in life to
you thanks for watching
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you